معنا من جامعه النجاح في نابلس مراسلنا
ليث جعار ليث بعد انسحاب قوات الاحتلال من
حرم الجامعه هل عرف مصير الطلبه الذين تم
اعتقالهم في هذا
الاقتحام نعم حتى هذه اللحظه لا يوجد اي
معلومات واضحه عن مصير الطلبه الذين تم
اعتقالهم والذي وصل عددهم الى
25 طالبا خلال اقتحام الاحتلال لحرم جامعه
النجاح في مدينه نابلس خلال ساعات الليله
حيث حاصر
الاحتلال الجامعه والحرم الجامعي من كافه
المحاور وقام بفتح ابواب الجامعه
والاقتحام بعشرات الاليات العسكريه حيث
اقتحم يعني معظم المباني في داخل الحرم
الجامعي القديم
وقام بالاعتداء على الجامعه وضرب بعضهم ما
ادى الى نقل اصابتين الى المستشفى قوات
الاحتلال حاصرت المنطقه تحديدا المنطقه
التي نتواجد بها والتي كان يتواجد بها عدد
من الطلبه في الاعتصام الذي دعا له المجلس
او مجلس اتحاد الطلبه برئاسه الكتله
الاسلاميه الذراع الطلابي لحركه المقاومه
الاسلاميه حماس والذي جاء فيه ل يعني
للمطالبه
ببعض المطالب النقابيه في الجامعه و من
ضمنها قضيه تقسيط الفصل الدراسي وا يعني
ليتسنى لكافه الطلبه التسجيل
و التسجيل والاستمرار في العمليه
التعليميه في ظل الوضع الاقتصادي الراهن
في الذي الذي تعيشه او يعيشه في تعيشه
الاراض الاراضي الفلسطينيه في الضفه
الغربيه وفي كافه
عموم الاراضي المحتله قوات الاحتلال يعني
اعتقلت 25 طالبا اعتدت على امن الجامعه
وايضا خربت ممتلكات او بعض ممتلكات
الجامعه العبث بمحتويات الطلبه ومصادره
هواتفهم واجهزتهم المحموله و يعني وال و
حواسيبهم وايضا قام الاحتلال ب يعني
التنكيل ببعضهم والتحقيق معهم ميدانيا هذا
ياتي في اطار استمرار العمليه العسكريه في
الضفه الغربيه و واستمرار الاقتحامات
المتواصله التي شهدتها الضفه الغربيه خلال
ساعات الليله حيث اقتحم الاحتلال ايضا
مدينه قلقيليه وقام بهدم منزلين يعودان
لاسيرين محررين بحجه البناء بدون ترخيص
وايضا في مدينه يطا جنوب الخليل كان هناك
ك اقتحام لجيش الاحتلال ومداهم لعدد من
المنازل في مدينه نابلس وجنوب مدينه نابلس
تحديدا قريه بورين قام الاحتلال ب
والمستوطنين بحرق مركبه تعود لاحد
المواطنين العمليات العسكريه والاقتحامات
متواصله تحديدا منذ السابع من اكتوبر حيث
باتت الضفه الغربيه على صفيح ساخن نتيجه
للاقتحامات المتواصله هنا في جامعه النجاح
اداره الجامعه دعت لمؤتمر
صحفي في تمام الساعه التاسعه فيما دعا
مجلس اتحاد الطلبه لمؤتمر اخر في تمام
الساعه الساعه الواحده ظهرا للوقوف على
المستجدات واخر التطورات في قضيه الاقتحام
الذي حدث فجر هذا اليوم شكرا جزيلا لك ليت
جعار كنت معنا من جامعه نجاح في نابلس